Interesting thing going on with uh
Deportations of undocumented immigrants you'll remember that our current president promised to be the big deporter
He'd get the country cleaned up of the not the best people that Mexico has been sending us law and order all of that type
Of thing and it is true that the Trump administration has been bragging about and has been making more arrests, right?
immigration officials from ICE have been making more
Arrests for people who are on who have immigration status violations since he became president of the United States
But more arrests does not mean more deportations especially when the arrests are pretty haphazard
Deportations are actually down under Trump now. I'm not complaining. I'm not passing a value judgment on this
I'm just pointing out to you that the rhetoric has been
Everybody's gonna go out, and then they can come back in maybe legally through a beautiful door in the as. Yell as yet-to-be-built
Wall that Mexico will pay for but deportations are down?
The numbers show that the Trump administration is on pace for fewer
deportations in 2017 than in 2016 under President Barack Obama and
There are 43 percent more arrests, so how do the numbers add up more arrests way more arrests?
But way fewer deportations the pledge from Trump was to arrest and deport so-called
Criminal illegal aliens three million drug dealers that Trump says are around and gang members
And other criminals who have committed crimes in addition to being undocumented in the United States Isis having trouble finding them
Right 43 percent more arrests by ICE, but it's mostly people with no criminal record who are just in the U.S.
undocumented in addition Trump's rhetoric around immigration has made it so that a ton of
Nonprofits have raised way more money in donations. They are now providing
Pro bono legal help to undocumented immigrants, and that is slowing down
Deportation so consider the big picture of what's happening here Trump wants to keep us safe
So he says we're going to start arresting way more people and deporting them. ICE rather than targeting
specific undocumented immigrants
Who have committed violent and other crimes and would qualify for quick
Deportation ICE starts haphazardly arresting everybody with an immigration status violation it
Fills up the system with people that are low priority with deportation
many of them end up getting free legal representation as a result of Trump's rhetoric and then the entire law enforcement and
Immigration and legal apparatus gets gummed up because it's full of people who have been arrested on
Immigration status violation violations, but actually haven't committed any crimes it's backwards
It's a total gongshow, and if your question is well. How will the Trump administration talk about this?
They'll just say
Isis doing a fantastic job
Tremendous really did you know arrests are up a lot of people didn't know that but they are we're arresting more illegals than ever before
Stunning really amazing what Barron can do with computers? They're going out and maybe someday
They'll come back in but they're just being arrested by ice and deportations are down if you are a committed Trumpets
How do you defend this how do you justify this and again? I'm not saying. This is a good thing
I'm not saying I support the policy, but if you're a Trumpets , and you believed what Trump was going to do
How do you defend this or do you just pretend? It's not going on?
The video you just finished watching was made possible by you through the membership program. You can sign up for membership at david pakman.com slash membership
We are viewer supported independent media. You can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of your membership